comme stefano et ses amis ils sont une
cinquantaine à avoir répondu présent à
l'opération de protection des mangroves
ce matin sur le site de coco l'échelle
au quartier volga plage à fort de france
parce que des amis à nous on proposé et
qu'on a trouvé que les été bonne c'est
un geste éco citoyen et donc ça nous a
plu ici depuis des années la mangrove
est constament agressés par des dépôts
sauvages mais aussi des résidus
polluants de l'activité portuaire
voisine hante un contexte insalubre qui
a poussé certains riverains à
délocaliser leurs activités en bateau
était juste à côté
et c'est vrai que l'était pas forcément
sécurité entre de mauvais temps déjà et
puis ce moment par rapport à la wii fit
avec des recettes autour de toutes
sortes de déchets donc voilà donc
c'était assez compliqué pour moi de
pouvoir travailler d'avoir un bateau en
sécurité un boulot quel moment je
pouvais sortir est tombé sion en objet
que toi mais quelque chose
donc ce n'est pas forcément évident pour
moi c'est à la force des bras et à
l'énergie de la bonne conscience que les
bénévoles tentent de retirer les trop
nombreux déchets accumulés
un chantier considérable impossible a
terminé en l'espace d'une journée
on a vraiment renouveler cette opération
régulièrement et encore avec plus de
monde continue et recommencer
recommencer régulièrement sensibiliser
l'ensemble des martiniquais à votre avis
d'une démarche vraiment site web
il faut une action politique derrière
une démarche citoyenne louis minne
action politique ce sera encore mieux
donc bienvenue aux politiques qu'ils ont
envie de dire au delà du ramassage
l'association ou of the sea race in law
mais soit rappelé le rôle capital des
mangroves sur nos écosystèmes tropicaux
c'est un cri d alerte en fait sur sur
l'état de cet écosystème donc ce n'est
pas seulement un simple nettoyage
voilà on a une vision plus lointaine
justement via l'éducation pour que les
gens comprennent c'est quoi l'importance
des membres en martinique au terme de la
journée une tonne de déchets dont 25 kg
de piles et de batteries ont été
ramassés par les bénévoles
des chiffres qui rappelle qu'une action
citoyenne peut représenter un nouveau
souffle pour notre nature